you
but I knew it worked so I was very
passionate about it and I knew the
science was there it was it was very
marginalized and grossly underutilized
as a therapy for epilepsy and I felt
that it had a similar capacity maybe
even a greater capacity for other things
outside of seizures and epilepsy so then
I kind of embarked on many different
experiments to test and evaluate
nutrition in particular the ketogenic
diet and using nutritional ketosis as
medicine and and that was a springboard
how specifically did the ketone esters
affect Navy divers so they have not well
they have not been used in Navy divers
in a registered clinical trial ok so
right now we have a registered clinical
trial with Duke and the protocol is
there are people in the field using it
and that communicate with me
in various capacities and they they
measure blood so they are sort of their
own end of one experiments but there are
many and of one experiments going on and
that feedback has very very helpful for
me to understand what works what doesn't
work what maybe does not work optimal as
far as dosing and then I sort of apply
that to like our animal studies and our
animal studies that are published some
of that information helps us to develop
the clinical trials we have at Duke now
and the protocol for that is is very
[Music]
it's it's kind of simple in that they
just do a modified and sort of Atkins
diet Atkins like diet or modified
ketogenic diet that's pretty liberal and
I think most people in the fitness
community follow a similar ketogenic
diet type approach and the requirement
is that you just get ketones up 2.5
million molar and they they choose
people that are sort of in an age range
of the Navy SEALs I guess you could say
I have maybe more of an athletic
background so they're kind of surrogates
for the seals I guess you could say and
they do they measure everything from
cardiovascular AG brain active
they put an arterial catheter a mass
spec and they look at blood gases and
Wow and everything you think of and
they're inside probably the most
advanced hyperbaric system on the planet
and they're also submerged and they're
also playing a flight simulator and
they're peddling a bike at the same time
so it's a very it's a very complicated
setup and a very very cool experiment
you could only do these sorts of
experiments at Duke University but they
just put them on a ketogenic diet for
three days and they give a supplement
right before they get in and it puts
them into a mild state of ketosis like
maybe a state that I'm in right now
hmm but not a huge whopping dose of a
ketone ester because they're not FDA
approved yet actually we're in the
process and I think maybe they are now
but and then in futures we can we can do
that for the particular type of ketone
ester that prevents seizures so we're
working with that now so the studies
that are being done now with oxygen
toxicity are to basically replicate what
a diver would experience on a mission in
regards to the partial pressure of
oxygen that's being inhaled and so
they're inside a hyperbaric chamber and
they have a mask on and they have people
assisting them if they actually have a
seizure they push them to the edge of a
seizure and there's basically EEG
signatures that will tell you warn the
person looking at the data that an
impending seizure about to happen and
that's when they cut off the experiment
how much I was amazed that something
like this got IRB approved but it is is
a registered clinical trial and clinical
trials that go and and it's a testament
to Duke and their their staff Bruce
Derek is one and Richard moon and Claude
piano doe see these are all icons in the
field of military of dive medicine you
would say so if I tried to do it it
wouldn't get passed so they have the
expertise in the background and decades
of experience doing this kind of
research so that research is ongoing the
pilot study has been done
now 40 participants are going through
this protocol and then the next round
what we want to do is do sort of an
extended ketogenic diet because we do
think special operations guys we do
think the diet is feasible for special
operations people to follow maybe not
the whole general military but for
Special Ops a low-carb modified
ketogenic diet is feasible and now
exogenous ketones are palatable
tolerable and efficacious for elevating
ketones so we have sort of two
technologies one being a specialized
diet and other being a specialized
supplement that if consumed will protect
the individual likely better than
anticonvulsant drugs that we have and
not only would it protect them from
oxygen toxicity seizures which makes
diving safer we think it also has a
capacity after you are adapted to the
diet has the capacity to preserve
performance resilience so if you were at
you know one atmosphere on land and you
follow a ketogenic diet your performance
is probably not going to increase that
much so some people advocate that a
caged egg diet will enhance performance
under certain conditions in certain
types of athletes or a ketone ester who
will enhance performance I'm not totally
convinced of that data and I'm a
ketogenic diet researcher so I should be
biased so I think but I do think that
when you take an elite level warfighter
and put him into a situation where his
performance will be compromised and he's
in a state of nutritional ketosis that
his performance will be maintained in
that extreme environment we call that
performance resilience so we do research
with NASA on NASA extreme environment
Mission Operations where we live in a
hyperbaric habitat or we live in an
environment that's an extreme
environment and in in these cases we are
looking to basically maintain a level
performance or prevent a performance
decrement right so that's sort of the
idea here there's you go on social media
there's lots of discussion and
and arguing about is a ketogenic diet
best for right strength athletes
bodybuilders elite level marathon
runners cyclist things like that that's
where most of the discussion is not so
much in the I think I'm glad I'm not
studying the ketogenic diet for sports
performance it's kind of interesting and
I keep up on it and I contribute even to
some papers but I think the real the
low-hanging fruit of benefits of the
ketogenic diet are for people who really
need it like people that are overweight
people with type 2 diabetes people have
seizures of course and then also the
warfighter who's subjecting themselves
to particular extreme environments where
we know the diet can be followed in his
operational setting and we know from
animal data and emerging human data and
that it would be beneficial in that
environment
[Music]
[Laughter]